we have three introducers tonight which
i think is a record of politics and
prose followed by the author who I
promise will speak longer than any or
all of us Michael Patrick McDonald is
here tonight and it's good to see people
come out despite all of the efforts of
Mother Nature to keep us out of the
store today Edward his last name I've
never been told Edward Hoyt and Matt
Bowles are here from the Irish Arts
Festival in town and they're gonna
introduce Michael Patrick Donald and
thanks very much for coming hey thanks
indeed for coming out it's been a
wonderful week in a horrible week at the
same time but unfortunately we got most
of our events up despite it as he said
the best efforts of Mother Nature to
stop us so your commitment to see mr.
McDonald today I hope will be rewarded
with a UH with a fun reading and a fine
discussion of his important book it's
the last day of our festival so at this
point I have generally listed the events
we still have um the only thing I can
mention is that the Keegan theatres
plays they're still gonna be one or two
more performances so check our website
and and with the Keegan theatre on their
box office line to see them otherwise
our website is www.seannal.com over
quickly to Matt balls Matt as a graduate
student in Peace Studies and conflict
resolution at American University and
that's where I ran into mr. McDonald and
he has a relationship with mr. McDonald
so and the introduction I can give will
be superseded by him well I met Mike
McDonald
last summer in the north of Ireland
actually we were both volunteering as
international observers on the garage
road and
Portadown monitoring the marching season
there was there the mic started to tell
me about Southie we had some long nights
of coffee and tea and that kind of stuff
and began talking about his neighborhood
that he comes from in South Boston and
many similarities and differences to the
communities in the north of Ireland
Mike's book All Souls is about growing
up in the colony projects in South
Boston when Mike was 8 years old the
race riots broke out over forced busing
liberal experiments to integrate the
poorest schools in South Boston as he
grew up he watched an Irish mafia create
an empire of drugs and violence which
infiltrated his community also promoting
the infamous code of silence and as
violence and suicide rose up the number
one code on the street was never to
snitch and this was also coupled by the
media which attended conspicuously to
ignore the social problems in South
Boston and right off things like
violence and drug addiction as a black
problem but all souls is not only about
the misery and squalor of poverty quite
to the contrary in fact it's a raw
honest an incredibly human account of
real life it's it's told most of it
through the eyes and heart of a child
struggling to make sense of the events
going on around him and to find his
place in it Mike McDonald has become a
prominent nonviolent activist in Boston
he has organized Boston vigil groups the
organizing communities to come together
and speak out against violence to speak
out against the neglected dead
he's organized gun buyback programs and
works regularly with youth in Boston on
alternatives to violence All Souls is
not another story about making it out in
fact it's about triumphing triumphing
within it's a vivid illustration of the
often hellish conditions endured by
America's poor but at the same time it's
full of love and pride for Southie the
best place in the world ladies and
gentlemen it's my distinct pleasure to
bring to you this evening a personal
friend of mine an extraordinary
individual and a couple out there please
welcome Michael Patrick McDonald's
[Applause]
thank you
the book begins and ends on All Souls
Day when we organized a vigil annually
for all those who had died too young in
the neighborhood mostly from crime
violence drugs and I'm gonna start
reading with the end of the first
chapter which takes place at the vigil
when it was my turn to go up and say the
names of my own brothers who had died
young it was my turn I stepped up to the
microphone with my four candles one for
each of my dead brothers I took a deep
breath and looked at each candle as if
they had the names written on them I
didn't know right then who was alive and
who was dead in my family and the
candles didn't give me any clue what's
up with all the fixin's who had broken
their style and sit awake by getting up
there and saying their loved ones names
throughout speaker Southie of all places
the best place in the world the kids I
thought trying to remember my brothers
names I knew they were right there in
the church but I still couldn't remember
who they were I looked for them scanning
the entire crowd but there were so many
faces the crowd stared back at me and
for a long time I looked for my family
among the faces of the living and of the
Dead my oldest memories are of my mother
crying I don't know how old I was but I
remember looking up from the floor and
seeing her sitting on the old trunk that
her father had carried from Ireland when
he was 18 in search of some good luck in
America she was only crying a little and
tried to hide it for me when she saw
that I'd noticed I calmed into her lap
and asked her why she was sad she told
me then about her baby who died and gone
to heaven
she said his name was Patrick Michael
but that it was all gonna be okay now
because we had someone watching over us
praying for us every day she told me
that I'd taken Patrick Michaels place
and that she'd switched the name around
calling me Michael Patrick because the
Irish always said it was bad luck to
name a child after another who had died
yet she showed me the light green knit
hat that someone had given Patrick she
couldn't remember who he wore that hat
home from the hospital when he was born
he was baptised him it still smelled
like a baby and had yellowing food
stains on it
it was all we had of Patrick there was
no picture ever taken of the soup
six week old baby throughout my whole
life whenever I saw her putting out very
different emotions from the people
around her
I've thought of my mother crying that
time when she thought no one would see
and I could never really get mad at her
the way most kids did it the parents I
could never judge or blame her for
anything in our lives
after I saw her cry for Patrick Michael
I only wanted to protect her
I was born at Columbia Point housing
project on the South Boston Dorchester
waterfront actually I was born in
hospital across the city most children
in Columbia Point were born around the
same time I was were delivered in their
project departments since back in the
60s ambulances wouldn't enter the
development without a police escort many
of these children were born before the
ambulance arrived long after it was
called and many of this generation had
birth defects I was lucky I was two
weeks late my mother had planned ahead
and arranged through Catholic Charities
for the other kids to be placed in
foster homes during her stay in the
hospital as soon as they were placed she
called the police to pick her up she was
told she'd have to meet them a mile down
the road outside of Columbia Point she
didn't mind and off she went and it's a
good thing she had the extra time to
make arrangements because when I was
born I was almost 13 pounds and had
given my mother 20 hours of labor I held
the record for birth weights in Boston
and my always told everyone how the
doctors and patients came from all parts
of Beth Israel Hospital to see me in the
nursery she said I was twice the size of
the other infants while they all cried
kicking their legs with eyes sealed
closed
I was quiet with two big spooky eyes she
said staring around the room and
observing all who would come to observe
me from behind the glass window I was my
mother's ninth child with two sisters
and six brothers before me including
Patrick and we always did include
Patrick in the count the family had
settled them to Columbia Point project
three years before I was born our mother
was still married to David MacDonald but
he was nowhere to be seen
according to Grandpa Maya's father the
marriage of his oldest daughter had
fulfilled everything he'd expected of it
on the day of her wedding grandpa woke
my up and told her to get up for the
market assuming to the marriage David
MacDonald beat my mother fractured his
skull in two occasions and broke her
ribs on another to this day though Mauer
remind you of that one time she knocked
out his teeth with one good kick
Dave McDonnell was an entertainer like
MA he played country-western music on
the guitar and Byron's throughout Boston
they met each other in a Valentine's Day
minstrel show at the parish hall ma had
entered the show and played her Irish
accordion while her four younger sisters
step dance
Maui's told us that when she first laid
eyes on David MacDonald playing Davy
Crockett she immediately remembered that
she'd had a terrible dream about him a
nightmare about a bad marriage
nonetheless ma married him at the age of
19 and before long they became a musical
duo but the good times were few he was
an alcoholic and further along in their
marriage he would disappear on his wife
and kids
a womanizer ma called him my older
brothers and sisters don't remember
seeing him around much occasionally
they'd hear him back in the house and
learned to expect the yelling and things
breaking ma we said there was no such
thing as divorcing your husband back
then he lived with whatever you had
married even if it was all turning to
help when she went to father Murphy
about the cheating and abuse he told her
you're a Catholic make the best of it
for her drinking too much was one thing
disappearing and going out with other
woman was another and the beatings were
bad but not showing up for your own baby
son's funeral when I confronted David
MacDonald about being down at the local
bar well his son's tiny casket was
carried through st. Thomas Church he
said that he'd seen too many buddies go
down in Korea to give a [ __ ] about one
baby dying
that was the official end of the
marriage ma had already started to take
care of the kids on her own with
financial help from welfare it's while
living in Columbia Point them I realized
sooner kids were surviving without any
help from her husband anyway money or
anything else she was alone when she had
to shove three of her kids into a bush
to hide from a shootout between two
speeding cars she was alone when she had
to confront a drunk mother about her
teenage son trying to strangle my sister
Mary to death when she was five she was
alone when her kids came home with
stories of being chased down and beaten
being white and mostly black
neighborhood and she was alone when she
ran through the project banging on
neighbors doors frantically trying to
breathe life back into the mouths of her
baby already dead in her arms
grandpa was the one my turn to when she
did need a man and she'd have to be
desperate foul because the two of them
didn't get along grandpa we said didn't
I tell you or else you made your bed a
lie in it
my own grandpa had brought Patrick to
the emergency room of Children's
Hospital the night before his death
Patrick was having trouble breathing my
thought he had a crew I had no health
insurance and Medicaid was a year away
the hospital turned the baby away ma
says that the hospital had filled its
quota of what were called charity cases
they didn't need to take anymore that
night they said it wasn't an emergency
case the next day Davi the oldest and
the family found Patrick not moving in
the crib lying still and blue the
coroner said he died of pneumonia and
should have been in the hospital
Mao later asked a lawyer about suing the
hospital for neglect the boy said there
was no case the hospitals weren't
required to admit welfare babies with no
insurance ma says when you lose a baby
it's the worst feeling in the world
because a baby depends on its mother for
everything and so ultimately it's always
the mother's fault
I suppose that's why she ran around with
the dead baby in her arms a baby they
hadn't been allowed into the hospital in
a housing project that ambulances
wouldn't come to it was her baby her
fault and she was gonna do whatever she
could do as a mother which at that point
wasn't much and our and my earliest we
lived in Columbia Point project and we
were part of a small and disappearing
white minority in that housing
development and like a lot of the other
white families who had left Columbia
Point we ended up getting a place in the
all-white mostly Irish housing projects
of South Boston a lot of my neighbors
growing up in South Boston and the
Oklahoma project had originally come
from Columbia Point or one of the other
one of the other housing projects that
where they had been part of a dwindling
white minority and for a long time in
Boston the housing projects were very
segregated when we ended up in South
Boston and Oconee project it was like we
had died and gone to heaven to end up in
a neighborhood with so many families
like our own so many who were Irish and
and who was parent female-headed
households we had spent a little bit of
time in Jamaica Plain working-class
neighborhood working-class to
middle-class neighborhood a lot of - at
homes a lot of Irish but it was just
kind of a whole different scene and we
really didn't fit in there either so we
went when
ended up in Oh colony in South Boston it
was like we really wanted to belong
there and be part of the neighborhood
but it was difficult because the
neighborhood is so South Boston as a
whole in a colony even more so has
always had a kind of suspicion of
outsiders and we were Outsiders even
though we were probably more Irish than
a lot of the people in the neighborhood
because my mother's parents were from
Ireland and my mother played the
accordion at local bars she was very
much part of the the Irish scene in
Boston and played traditional music on
the accordion we grew up with a lot of
the history and culture in us a lot of
the other people in the neighborhood
were more distantly Irish but we're
really into it and the Shamrock some uh
pecans flew everywhere and but when we
were accepted into a colony eventually
we really felt like we're in the best
place in the world and it wasn't long
before busing happened in Boston and
judge garetty's ruling to desegregate
the schools and phase one of busing
which matched up South Boston poorest
white neighborhood with Roxbury the
poorest black neighborhood in the city
South Boston's lower end which includes
three large housing projects was found
in 1994 to have the highest
concentration of white poverty in
America and this is something that even
even as recently as 1994 we still had a
hard time accepting a lot of people in
the neighborhood didn't even want to
acknowledge the poverty that does exist
in the neighborhood
nevermind all the other social problems
that come with that or on drugs and
violence and so forth
I'm gonna read something from when
busing happened and I was eight years
old when the riots broke out in South
Boston and South Boston really was kind
of the flashpoint for a lot of the the
racial violence around busing in Boston
and but for us it was probably the most
exciting period of our lives as kids
growing up in the projects to be part of
those rights
and the chapter is called fight the
power twas on a dreary Thursday morn as
the busses rolled along they came up to
our boarded town with orders from the
law desegregate and integrate oh you
will pay the price of loss of pride
humility and even your children's lives
but Southie spirit was so strong they
made us a barrack town they took their
horses dogs and guns and set them on the
crowd the TPF their sticks did crack on
the young and old alike but united still
our spirits I will fight for freedom's
right
Marston's on the accordion started to be
all about the busting she played them at
the rally sit-ins and fundraisers for
the struggle all over Southie the song
sounded like a lot of the Irish rebel
songs we grew up with they had the same
tunes but the words had changed so come
on Selby head on high they'll never take
our pride the Black and Tans the
murderous regiments who'd wreaked havoc
on Ireland on behalf of the English
crown became the TPF tactical police
force the special force that was turning
our town into a police state the Queen
of England was gone from our songs to
her place was taken by Judge Garrity the
federal judge who'd mandated busting the
law of the land
judge Garrity and traitors - we've just
begun to fight Garrity had an Irish name
which made it all the worse as he Irish
hated nothing more than a traitor that's
why we hated Ted Kennedy he'd sat it
with the bus and to what was seen as the
biggest traitor of all being from the
most important Irish family in America
the English themselves weren't
completely absent from our struggle
though they ran the Boston Globe all
behind the whole thing my friends and I
started stealing stacks of the globe
left outside supermarkets in the early
mornings we could sell them for a dime
to people on their way to work who'd
have been paying a quarter for one for
us kids that's when I found out the
globe was the enemy we tried to sell it
in Southie but too many people said they
wouldn't read that liberal piece of
trash if it was free there was to blame
for the busing with all its attacks on
South Boston I heard a few people say it
was a communist paper not only the
Communists of the rich English keeping
up their hate for the Irish and Southie
my mother's boyfriend Coley told me he
showed me all the names of the globe's
owners and editors Winship Taylor all
wasp seasoned white anglo-saxon
Protestants forever getting back at the
Irish for chasing them out of Boston boy
was I confused now that the English were
involved
we'd always hated the English for what
they did to the Irish whatever that was
listening to Maya's Irish songs I
thought it was in the past and across a
great big ocean well now it was right
here in Southie I was glad to be doing
my pot anyway still in the Boston Globe
and making a couple bucks on their loss
the rich English liberal communist
bastards that September my letter
skipped the first week of school the
whole neighborhood was boycotted what
was supposed to be just the high school
kids boycotting well we all wanted to
show a loyalty to the neighborhood I was
meant to be starting the third grade at
San Agustin school I had enrolled Kevin
and Cathy in the sixth and seventh
grades there as well Frankie was going
to South be high and Mary and Joe were
being sent to mostly black Roxbury so
they really had something to boycott but
on the first day Kevin and Cathy begged
me not to send them come on ma please I
piped in it was still warm outside and
we wanted to join the crowds that were
just then lying on the streets to watch
the bus loads of black kids come into
Southie the excitement built as police
helicopters hovered just above our
third-floor windows police in riot gear
stood guard on the rooftops of our
colony and the national news camped out
on every corner
Ma said ok and we ran up to Darius Court
along the busing room where in simpler
times we'd watch the neighborhood st.
Patty's Day Parade the whole
neighborhood was out even the mothers
from the stoop made it up to Darius
Court nightgowns and all mrs. Coyne up
on the rooftop in our house dress got
arrested before the buses even started
rolling through the neighborhood
everyone knew she was a little soft
I thought the excitement that day must
have been a little bit too much for her
she ran up to the roof and called the
police [ __ ] lovest and traders and
started dancing and singing James Brown
songs say it loud I'm black and I'm
proud she nearly fell off the roof
before one cop grabbed her from behind
and restrained her everyone was laughing
at that one big fat mrs. coin rolling
around on the rooftop kicking and
screaming with a cop in full riot gear
on top of her little disturbances like
that broke out here and there but most
people were too intent on seeing the
busses roll to do anything that might
get them carted away I looked up the
road and saw a squadron of police
motorcycles speeding down Dorchester
Street right along the curb as if they
would run over anyone who wasn't on the
sidewalk the buses were coming police
sirens wailed as hundreds of cops on
motorcycles aimed at the crowds of
as in kids to clear the way for the law
of the land bacon I smell bacon a few
people yelled sniffing at the cops
I knew that meant the cops were pigs as
the motorcycles came closer I fought to
get back into the sidewalk it was too
crowded
I ran further into the road to avoid one
motorcycle when two more came at me from
the middle of the street I had to run
across to the other side of the road
with a crowd quickly cleared a space for
me on the sidewalk all the adults
welcomed me patted me on the shoulder
are you all right those pricks would
even kill a kid Pig someone else shouted
I thought I'd lost Kevin and Cathy but
just then I saw them sitting on top of a
mailbox up the street for a good view of
the buses they waved to me laughing
because they'd see me almost get run
over the road was cleared and the buses
rolled slowly we saw a line of yellow
buses like there was no end to them I
couldn't see any black faces though and
I was looking for them some people
around me started by when they finally
got a glimpse of the bus through the
crowd one woman cross and a few others
copied it I thought I'd never see that
a-come said an old woman next to me she
was trembling and so was everyone else I
could feel it myself it was a feeling of
loss of being beaten down of humiliation
in minutes though it had turned to anger
rage and hate just like in those Irish
rebel songs I'd heard all my life like
The Ballad of James calmly guards
Kirsten you England you cruel-hearted
monster your deeds they would shame all
the devils and he'll accept we changed
the words to God's curse on your Garrety
smashed a burst of flying glass and all
that rage exploded
we'd all been waiting for it and so
heard the police in riot gear it felt
like a gunshot but it was a brick went
right through a bus window then all hell
broke loose I saw a milk crate fire from
the other side of the street right for
my face more bricks
sticks and bottles smashed against the
buses as police pulled out their billy
clubs and charged with their riot
shields and aligned formation through
the crowds teenagers were chased into
the project and beaten to the cement
wherever they were caught I raced away
about a block from the fraid to a spot
where everyone was chanting here we go
Southie here we go like a battle cry
that's when I realized we're at war I
started chanting too at first just moved
my lips because I didn't know if a kid's
voice would ruin the strong chant but
then I belted it out just as a few other
kids I didn't
during the course the kids in the crowd
all looked at each other as if we were
family
this is great I thought I'd never had
such an easy time as this making friends
in Southie the buses kept passing by
speeding now and all I could see in the
windows will black hands with the middle
fingers up at us
still no faces though the buses got
through the crowd surrounded by the
police motorcycles
I saw Frankie running up towards Southie
high along with everyone else what are
you doing out here yelled get your ass
home he said there was another riot with
the cops up at the high school and off
he ran with the others
not far behind were Kevin and his
friends he shouted the same thing at me
get your ass home I just wanted to find
my now and make sure she wasn't beaten
or arrested or anything so I ran home
the project was empty everyone had
followed the buses up the st. Paddy's
parade route ma wasn't home but the TV
was on with live coverage of the riots
at Southie high every channel I turned
to showed the same thing I kept flipping
the dial looking for my family and
catching glimpses of what seemed to be
all the people I knew hurling stones are
being beaten by the police or both this
is big I thought it was scary and
thrilling at the same time and I
remember the day we'd moved into this
neighborhood when Maya said I look just
like Belfast and they were in the best
place in the world
I kept changing the channels looking for
my family and I didn't know any more
whether I was scared or thrilled or if
there was any difference between the two
anyhow I was only eight but I was part
of it all part of something bigger than
I'd ever imagined part of something that
was on the national news every night and
the years following the court order in
1974 a lot of people in South Boston
especially in the lower end where I grew
up around the housing projects dropped
out of school and we're also finding out
recently that coincidentally 1974-75 was
around the same time that the FBI made
its deal with Whitey Bulger who was the
neighborhood drug lord and and crime
boss and head of the Irish mafia and the
deal that they made with him was that
the agents of the FBI made a deal with
him given him permission to do as he
likes and to be protected in
for being an informant on the Italian
mafia across town so the past 25 years
actually from about that time till about
94 95 when whitey bulger went missing he
was actually working with the FBI and
helping to get the Italian mafia locked
up across town but all the while our own
young people were dying from crime drugs
suicide we've had a very high suicide
rate over the years we've had a high
rate of overdoses over the years and all
the while our own cultural tendencies I
think for denial combined with a code of
silence that was imposed on the
neighborhood by organized crime helped
to keep things quiet about what really
was going on in the neighborhood and all
those issues around poverty drugs crime
violence those are black things and the
you know the racial stereotyping in
media tended to reinforce that idea that
those are black things and people in
Southie certainly we're gonna go on with
that one and and despite all the you
know poverty in the neighborhood or
confusion in people's lives they would
they tended to be more of an obsession
with the idea that well we're not black
anyway at least we're not black so it
was confusing to grew up in a
neighborhood where you know you saw a
lot of the poverty the conditions and
housing projects with rats and
cockroaches and so forth but to always
be held up by the left as as the bastion
of white privilege in America and I've
always seen how how well the left and
the right worked together against this
particular population especially
considering in retrospect 1974 and 75
and and the the busing order and how it
was implemented in particularly pairing
up the poorest black neighborhood with
the poorest white neighborhood which was
either incredibly dumb or incredibly
brilliant on the part of the planners
because sometimes I think these things
are set up to fail and how that plan
combined with our own right-wing bigoted
politicians manipulation of the poppy
and Southey helped to increase the
divisions across Boston racially and I
ended up working years later in in
Roxbury Dorchester Matapan the black and
Latino neighborhoods in the city and
finding out how much I had in common
with people in those neighborhoods from
my own life experiences with the life
experiences of people in those
neighborhoods and the years following
bustin we saw a lot more young people
dropping out a lot of drug use and a lot
of my siblings my older siblings friends
died in those years in the late 70s
early 80s especially in the early 80s
South Boston was found to have had the
fastest growing homicide rate in Boston
and throughout the 80s and up until
recently we have one of the highest
overdose rates in the city of Boston and
some of this stuff is just starting to
come out now because Whitey Bulger has
been on the run and people are more free
to talk about those things and people
have been opening up a little bit it's
also a time right now when the
neighborhood's gentrifying really fast
and the neighborhood were losing the
neighborhood and for all the good things
about the place as well I'm gonna read
from something in the aftermath of
losing three of my brothers violently
one was a suicide but the other two were
related to organized crime in the
neighborhood
my brother Davi was the oldest he
committed suicide jumped off the roof
and that was something that I witnessed
at the age of 13 a year later my sister
Kathy went off the roof also in a
struggle over drugs and she was in a
coma for five months and to this days
very severely brain-damaged and possibly
paralyzed and a couple years later in 84
my brother Frankie four times Golden
Gloves champion boxer for all of New
England got involved in a bank job which
was for a lot of people the crime of
choice to get involved in an armored car
heist that would happen out in the
suburbs he was shot in the crossfire and
received a minor wound but was actually
knocked off by his own partner in crime
just to keep keep
quiet so you wouldn't end up in a
hospital and end up talking eight months
later my brother Kevin was found hanging
in prison and some people say he
committed suicide and some say he was
killed for it he knew about organized
crime in the neighborhood he died at the
age of 21 we had I grew up with a tense
10th or 10 of us all all together
growing up in South Boston and during
that time three of my brothers were lost
others went in all kinds of directions
my sister's a nurse in the operating
room at City Hospital and another
brother was lieutenant the Navy and and
I went on to be an activist and
community organizer but the last thing
I'm gonna read is just from the
aftermath period period of being a
little bit disillusioned with the
neighborhood and struggling with that
love-hate feelings before my mother
finally escapes and I think I like to
read this passage because it says a lot
about my mother's character as a
survivor having lost that many children
and how much energy she's put into
trying to help other people whatever way
she can and to keep keep spirit at all
times and my little brother
Seamus have two younger brothers that
are 10 years younger than me my little
brother Sheamus was in the habit of
calling the liquor store at the end of
our street the Irish mafia store and
sometimes he would say it louder than I
want to wanted to hear because we didn't
have an Irish mafia there's no such
thing as the Irish mafia and but the
little kids knew it was up and the
little kids had nicknamed the store the
Irish mafia store which was destroyed it
was the headquarters of organized crime
in South Boston right at the end of our
street coincidentally on the edge of a
huge housing project and near another
huge housing project a population with a
lot of pain and trouble in their lives
and definitely a lucrative market for
whitey Bulger's drug trade hey Mike you
got 50 cents so I can go to the iris my
fist or I heard sheamus's voice from
inside the dumpster I was about to toss
the trashing - he popped his head up and
laughed Stevie was in there - they said
they were playing cops and robbers while
hiding out from the bad guys
and who are the nevermind I said we'd
all talked about how the little kids had
been able to bounce back from the
tragedy they to live through Sheamus was
nine and Stevie eight and here they were
having the time of their lives making
their own fun in the same courtyards and
dumpsters where I'd fold Kevin around as
a kid I gave Seamus and Stevie $3 but I
told them they couldn't go to the Irish
mafia store order the clam shack and
then I knocked off a few other stores
that I knew had connections to what I
started to identify as the bad guys my
list didn't leave them with many places
to go and in the end they just tramped
off to Whitey's headquarters anyway we
didn't feel the same about our
neighborhood now that the kids were dead
my said she wanted nothing more than to
get the hell out but there was nowhere
to go I was getting 250 a month from
welfare less than a month's rent an
apartment outside the project's she was
going a hairdressing school hoping to
get a job but the people in the
neighborhood who had jobs usually had
factories and plants that bordered the
neighborhood losing them this was while
downtown cafes and wine bistros
continued to pack in the crowds of
yuppies taken over working-class
neighborhoods like chaol stone and the
North End with the rents outside the
project's going up we knew Southie was
next mile worked hard just to keep
herself busy after the kids were buried
she said she had no time to sit around
feeling sorry for herself thinking about
them she said they're in a better place
better off than the rest of us I went to
hairdressing school every morning and
spent the afternoon scut inherit the
local homeless shelter even though she
always found headlights walking on her
scissors afterward my love being around
the homeless she said it kept her going
listen to all their stories and sending
them off looking like a million bucks
she said when she got through with them
they looked like Johnny Cash conway
twitty or one of her other favorite
country stars well ma started to hang
out with the young gay men from
hairdressing school and go into gay
clubs she updated and sent the homeless
off with more like Cyndi Lauper then she
started volunteering nights at AIDS
wards giving complete makeovers hair
makeup nails and playing a recording in
between stories that kept everyone in
stitches stories about her husband's her
boyfriends and courtroom scenes with her
cousin Nellie ma said she wanted to help
the dying patients prepare to cross over
to the other side and she figured some
makeup and a few laughs we're as good as
the Rosary any day ma was going mad with
the makeover
so one time my Aunt Sally cried looking
into the mirror after ma got through
with her head she'd been given what ma
was calling the windswept look and the
helmet of orange hair plastered to
Sally's forehead and chubby cheeks
looked like a cyclone frozen over my
told us she looked like aizen Minnelli
and Sally said she wanted nothing to do
with Liza Minnelli my had plucked off
Sally's bushy eyebrows with the tweezers
and her chin whiskers - which was really
why Sally was crying oh shut up my snap
that her younger sister your husband
don't be thanking me now that I got rid
of your beard that night we heard a
gunshot on paterson way and Sally made
me walk her to the train station saying
anything was better than spending one
more minute with MA and her cuttin and
plucking ma was just doing whatever she
could to keep her mind off what she was
feeling
but the hearses kept rolling down
Dorchester Street we're in better days
we'd watch the st. Patty's Day Parade
and the anti bussing motorcades and
every time it was another Southie
mother's turn to see her child off at
Jackie O brains for no power it brought
my right back to reality she started
going to all the wakes even if she
didn't know the family and in about a
year she'd counted that she'd been to 32
all dead from suicide drugs or crime MA
started hanging out with the other woman
whose sons her daughter's had died and
she started cutting some of their hair
too until they learned to make sure they
went to the hairdresser's on a regular
basis so ma wouldn't have them walking
down Broadway and one of those
cosmopolitan hairdos she was bringing to
Southie from the gay clubs Denmark good
into the holy water after grandpa took
her on a trip to Fatima where the
Blessed Mother had appeared to the three
children holy water and haircuts Bao was
on a mission to give whatever she was
able to give she was always pulling
something out of her pocketbook whether
a piece of toast for the guys on the
wino wall or rock for someone he needed
strength
besides the scissors and jug of holy
water Ma's pocketbook was full of rocks
that she brought back from Fatima oh
thanks what's this for I asked my trying
to sound grateful and she handed me a
three pound rock she told me with it
that when grandpa and the other pilgrims
to Fatima had crawled on their knees to
the next holy site she'd run back to the
well we're the best Blessed Mother had
appeared and she was a lot a few stones
for herself get down on your knees for
our lady you damn fool grandpa told her
when she returned like Hollywood might
old
you should have seen the face on my
father like he was wearing the crown of
thorns himself I was inspired by her own
relationship with the Blessed Mother
saying she needed the rocks for some of
the mothers burying their kids in
Southie most people actually treasured
their rocks and some told me they kept
them in their pocketbooks always to
remind them of Helen and all her
strength I was worried about my on those
days with her running out to clubs and
blessing the mothers of our colony with
holy water but everyone else saw her as
an inspiration just to have gotten up in
the morning and put her spiked heels on
the right feet the mothers had lost one
kid didn't know how she could do it
having lost 4 and bow was even smiled
again as much as she could make herself
to she said that she had no other choice
except suicide and she couldn't do that
with Seamus and Stevie and all these
other people to look after within a few
years by about 1990 my mother had made
it out of South Boston with my younger
my two little brothers to try to give
them a different life out out in
Colorado
my older brother Joe had moved out there
and got a house and was able to bring
the rest of the family out there because
there was finally a way out just
economically of getting out of the
project and they've been there ever
since I left the neighborhood and left
the neighborhood kind of really
disillusioned and and really trying to
cut myself off mentally and emotionally
and spiritually from the neighborhood
but was drawn back four years later when
I left the neighborhood in 1990 I I did
got involved in community organizing and
activism work mostly in black and Latino
neighborhoods throughout the city
because in those neighborhoods people
were more open to talking about these
issues these issues that affected my
life so much and people were embraced me
in those communities and were willing to
hear my story and I worked with a number
of survivors from throughout the city
and we formed multiracial coalition's to
reduce violence in the city and we came
up with a number of initiatives some
stuff around community policing and
working on reducing some of the police
abuse that was happening in a lot of the
communities and some of the distance
that existed between the police and and
communities especially and by
in Latino neighborhoods but I had also
experienced that distance growing up in
in my my pot of South Boston especially
through busing in some of the distance
between law enforcement and the
community and some of the consequent
criminalization of the young people in
that neighborhood and I saw the same
thing happening in Roxbury we also
started a gun buyback program which we
ran for four years and collected a total
of 2,900 working guns and destroyed
every one of them a lot of them were
from gang members they were there were
some of them were from illegal gun
owners who had changed their mind about
having a gun in the home and we really
formed a pretty amazing survivor
movement across race and Boston and I
got involved with a group of mothers
from Charlestown Charles Townsend a
community that's always been likened to
South Boston it's very similar I was one
square mile has housing projects Irish
American community working-class also a
lot of poor and it was just kind of a
smaller version of Southie and maybe
even more more condensed and Charlestown
had experienced a number of homicides
over the years and had had the highest
number of the highest rate of unsolved
murders in the country and a lot of
murders that were happening Charlestown
would be witnessed by a hundred people
or so and and sometimes spilling out at
a bar sometimes hanging out in a park
and no one would testify because of
neighborhood loyalties and so forth that
had been built over the years also the
whole us against them mentality that
communities like this can can create
that South Boston had that Charles don't
have and lots of times our neighborhoods
like Roxbury in the black community can
have as well but a lot of that a lot of
that closing off of the neighborhood
especially in Southie and Charlestown
really was reinforced during the period
of busing when the that's when the walls
really went up
and Charlestown had suffered from a lot
of murders but the difference was at
this time when I was an activist I met
this group of mothers woman named Sandy
King whose two sons were murdered in
Charlestown one in 1986 one 1991 and a
woman named Pam meaness whose son was
murdered
also in 91 and they had started the
Charlestown after murder program and
this woman started coming out and a lot
of woman that also from the neighborhood
of Charlestown started coming out and
speaking up against the gangsters in
their community and they did a lot to
reform the way the police work in that
community the way the criminal justice
system works or you know for a long time
the criminal justice system would just
ignore Charlestown and the same with
Southie because it you know they would
just rely on the idea that well there's
a code of silence there we're not gonna
solve it anyway so it just allowed them
to do less work but these mothers really
stood up to all that and they also stood
up to the gangsters in the neighborhood
they were really brave and they also did
a lot to raise awareness about the
amount of pain that the violence can
cause on a family and they started
organizing vigils which I was I was most
moved by when I went to they invited me
one year to come speak at their vigil as
a survivor myself who was an activist
and when I went to their vigil after
years of working mostly in Roxbury
Dorchester Mattapan and walked into the
church at st. Catherine's these mothers
had decorated the church with all the
symbols the kinds of symbols of
Irishness that I had grown up with the
shamrocks and the Claddagh and the
tricolour all over the church and the
faces of these woman was so much like
the faces of my own neighbors would lost
their kids the pictures of their kids on
the altar were so much like my own
neighbors who had died young um over the
years
and that experience with the mothers in
Charlestown really helped me to go back
to South Boston the place that I really
actually loved so much and was still
being pulled by I eventually moved back
there and was able to bring back with me
a lot of the organizing experience I had
learned in black and Latino
neighborhoods as well as in Charlestown
as well as a lot of the survivors
themselves and we created a vigilance
Boston that we were running annually and
we did that with the help of some of
these other other mothers from
Charlestown and from across the city and
it really was for me the full circle and
and the completion of the the true
multiracial coalition that I've always
dreamed of seeing because a lot of times
and a lot of a lot of times people call
what people call multiracial coalition's
never seem to have white people who come
from where I come from so for me that
was incredible to to see that type of
real diversity in Boston especially
having lived through the types of
divisions through busing and so forth
and my my first feelings around seeing
some of these mothers get together
across the city across across race whose
sisterhood was so obvious across race
because they had very similar
experiences trying to raise children in
these types of neighborhoods where
organized crime lots of times will prey
on their children where policymakers
don't really work from the grassroots
they implement policy that doesn't
really take people's real lives into
account policies like busing and phase
one of busing which you know to match up
the poorest white and poorest black
neighborhoods and promote that kind of
violence for me it was the the emotion
that I had most around seeing these
mothers get together was anger because
it was really easy and that's that's
what that's what made me the most angry
is to see how easy it is to bring people
together on common ground and and how
difficult we sometimes make it I'm just
gonna finish up with reading from the
altar at the vigil when one year one
year when I went up to say my brothers
names I actually was kind of you know
stunned more or less and stopped and
really couldn't even remember their
names and the book leads back to that
moment that's how I found myself staring
out at a sea of faces looking for my
brothers among the living and the dead
I was looking for the truth about their
lives and about their deaths
like me everyone at that night's vigil
will forever be looking for the truth in
Southie when nothing is what it seems
standing at the altar I at last felt I
might be able to reconcile myself with
all my memories of confusion bloodshed
and betrayal and that I could do it with
love I love my family and I love Southie
these candles burned for my brothers I
stopped and took a deep breath then I
spoke up Davey Frankie Kevin and Patrick
and for all souls thank you we have time
for just a few questions and then
signing books if people have other
questions you can also ask me then but I
was amazed at a lot of the positive
response I got especially from young
people not only across city but Patil
Ian's in Southie of young people in
Southie because is this kind of a
generation gap around this troop selling
stuff young people really need to tell
the truth at this point about stuff in
their lives
because what I've seen happen over the
years is just you know people living
through trauma after trauma after trauma
that is suppressed and and repressed and
they're not allowed to feel and
acknowledge and talk about and I think
that that has everything to do with
being in a neighborhood that has one of
the highest suicide rates in America I
mean I think that the suicides come from
that kind of suppression of the truth a
lot of a lot of positive response I've
had some negative response from people
who had some fears about what was in the
book about them but I only wrote about
other people and so far as their lives
intersected with mine and these I only
wrote about my experiences and this is
my story but most of the I've been kind
of overwhelmed by the letters and and
even just people on the street saying
thanks for telling my story like they
feel it's their story as well so that's
that's been kind of a
and reassuring negative lead of this
book do you are organized crime in South
Boston has really fallen apart and
whitey Bulger's not very safe he's he's
an FBI informant and a lot of people
would be I said you know the Italians
the IRA and so forth a lot of people
that that um aren't too happy about the
fact that he was an informant all these
years so now I'm not worried about that
an organized crime in South Boston has
really fallen apart because nobody knows
who to trust anymore you know if he was
a snitch the person that you know
ingrained in us this whole idea that you
know it's the worst thing in the world
to be and and maintain the strict code
of silence and killed people who didn't
keep the Sons to find out that he's the
biggest Mitch of all that's very
confusing for everyone from the young
people all the way up to the other
people involved in organized crime and
nobody knows who to trust and people are
talking left and right it's all it's all
folk coming apart at the seams and the
past few weeks number of bodies have
been dug up around South Boston in
Dorchester lots of times when people are
murdered and a lot of the disappeared in
the neighborhood would be buried and
like outside the neighborhood and a lot
of thought of crime and violence would
happen outside the neighborhood because
we had to keep up this idea that you
know the the crime rate was low in the
neighborhood it's the safest place in
the world but now that's that's the
least of my worries
actually yeah yeah the media reporting
portrayals of Southie and the families
there and the politics has gotten any
better or has like changed over time
what you've already two years ago there
was an explosion of we've always had
suicides a lot of suicides was explosion
of young suicides two years ago and the
media
I felt so the Boston Globe which I think
in the past had been pretty unfair to
South Boston actually you know you know
I kind of exaggerated my that those are
my childhoods perceptions that it's the
devil incarnate but you know I do think
they were and fair and more recently
especially with the coverage of the
suicides they've kind of you know been
more aware of some of the social issues
in the neighborhood and more sensitive I
think to that and would cover the
suicide epidemic in a way that I thought
wasn't horrifying suicide or
sensationalizing it or or ignoring it
because normally in the past they would
have ignored the social issues that
existed in the lives of kids in Southie
like a lot of other people you know
because it's almost it was like only the
neighborhood was only paid attention to
for racial incidents and always
portrayed is you know the biggest racist
neighborhood in America and there are
other neighborhoods in Boston that have
the neighborhood that's probably the
neighborhoods that I consider the most
progressive neighborhoods so probably
even more racist than South Boston ever
was they're 100% white wealthy and it's
never been questioned why these
neighborhoods were white and but and
there's also a lot of there will be
housing projects that are kind of
cordoned off in those neighborhoods and
and if anything spills out of the
housing projects into the logic
progressive wealthy white community it's
they just get completely they'd rather
than dealing with the root causes for
violence whatever that might seep a lot
of the housing projects they're just so
quick to get them on the news saying
that this is this doesn't happen here
just to keep their I think to keep their
the property values high or whatever but
um this stuff doesn't happen here this
is very unusual this is stuff that
happens over there so South Boston
really is held up as as the racist
neighborhood and it's kind of unfair and
and racism is a huge American problem
all across this entire country and it
always seems to be held up in places
with the poorest whites you know it's as
as the the places that need to be broken
and that doesn't really benefit anyone
involved black or white boy
notwithstanding your efforts is there
still as you speak today
another McDonald family out there in
South Boston that's going through what
you went through there's gonna be
somebody here in 10 or 15 years that's
relating their experience like yours
other bus is still the same well what's
happening now in the neighborhood is
that the the biggest threat to the
neighborhood right now is gentrification
organized crime is falling apart
and there is a huge heroin epidemic
going on which is taking younger and
younger people 13 year-olds using heroin
and I believe that even that's the
legacy of this whole history of a
neighborhood that was controlled of a
controlled community and but even but
that's all disappear the populations
disappear and they're being pushed out
unfortunately and you know a lot of
times in our cities people celebrate the
reduction of crime and violence and
drugs and and don't really look at the
fact that what we're really doing a lot
of time is just completely replacing the
population making people homeless and
and also pushing them out to places will
they be more spread out and and less
noisy because uh you know the
directional going into poverty is
becoming more spread out in America
rather than in highly concentrated urban
ghettos and when it's spread out like
that it's just you know we won't really
notice it as much it'll be more
invisible people's lives will be the
same and we're not really dealing with
the real issues and and the existence of
poverty believe in a boom economy like
people may you know people just can't
believe that they're poor people out
there in neighborhoods like South Boston
you'll you'll hear of people celebrating
you know that the quality of life
improving in the neighborhood and so
forth but it's it's for completely new
population Charlestown the neighborhood
that I referred to before is probably
one of the wealthiest neighborhoods in
Boston now and and people do when these
mother when these mothers were
organizing against the code of silence
they were willing to
to die for what they believed in and to
speak up for their children and they
thought that they would be attacked by
gangsters and shot and the only people
attacking them or real estate agents
because it was at the same time that
that the neighborhood was fast
gentrifying and here they were in the
newspapers I'm talking about murder and
Charlestown and every time there was an
article about unsolved murders in
Charlestown there would be an even
bigger article the next day that was
kind of prompted by real estate agents
about Charlestown being the new hip hop
trendy neighborhood and and how safe it
is and so you can't help but wonder how
much a lot of this and well I have to
say also Roxbury is another neighborhood
that's that's being threatened the black
community in Boston it's just becoming
smaller and smaller and the outskirts of
Roxbury are being gentrified really fast
today and and people that are
gentrifying those areas around the
neighborhood kind of making it smaller
and smaller people who consider
themselves progressive for the most part
and don't want the word Roxbury on their
envelopes has to say Boston Oh 2 1 1 9
or they get really upset you know
because of that because of their own
racism really but um what's ironic of
course is that Roxbury and South Boston
the conversations you'll hear on the
streets and those neighborhoods are the
same conversation it's about people
losing their neighborhoods about people
who lose in the place that they love
that they've lived in for generations
and people having to move out of their
homes and find something affordable way
out some suburb on the edge of a highway
or something same conversations in
Roxbury and Southie we're having once
again we have so much in common
but we've been divided for so long but
there's really no movement to reverse
that into and to maintain some
affordability in the neighborhoods so
ten years from now it probably another
wealthy white neighborhood in Boston and
it's also at a time when the
neighborhood was those housing projects
anyway had become very diverse in South
Boston 50 50 % white 50 % of color but I
bet you anything those housing projects
will be
condominiums in a few years as well
because that's what's happened with a
lot of other housing projects and it's
almost like you know the deterioration
is part of the equation it deterioration
of these neighborhoods a lot of times
it's part of the equation because then
they become primed for gentrification
usually because of the deterioration you
know because some people would be
willing to move in and fix the place up
and people will start to welcome that
then people start to lose their home and
it starts to question it but it's too
late it's the same pattern you see over
and over so I think if the the the
biggest change that's happening is uh is
that you know just being you know
wealthy white neighborhood multiracial
coalition's you walk in there you tell
people you're from Southie how hard is
it to get past their initial reaction
media inspired oh you're in fun races
place on earth that was always difficult
um all my life to admit that I was from
South Boston and a lot of times I see it
today to young people if they're in
mixed company you know outside of South
Boston they will say that they're from
some other part of Boston like
Dorchester which is more more diverse
and that's usually if they're around
anyone of color or also around anyone
who to them looks like a liberal that's
how you know how people usually anybody
that looks like they're white and they
come from like they have money to them
is just that's that's odd that's what
liberal means to people himself Southie
and you know that's just the perception
real and true or not it's the way it is
and in the reasons why that perception
has been created but so people would be
very careful to say they're from there
when I when I stood first started doing
this work I just didn't care anymore and
in the black neighborhoods I was just
you know once I told my story to people
people immediately had identified with
my story and expressed a lot in common
with me and and people were shocked
really you know in the black coming
these people were really shocked to hear
that this stuff happen happens and can
happen in the white neighborhood and
that the such thing is you know how they
concentrated poor white neighborhood and
what's what I've heard expressed to me
from a lot of kids of color is that
they're just the kind of relief to meet
me because they're almost made to
believe by our culture that it's
something in their blood that all this
stuff is in their blood you know the
drugs the crimes of violence that it's
it's and it's a relief a lot of times to
find out that the the socioeconomics of
it
and black people in this country are
disproportionately poor disproportionate
to their numbers and the greater
population but but it's important for
people to know that that class is an
issue and that these social problems are
related to have everything to do with
money and who has it and who doesn't
have it
and and that's a relief to a lot of
young young people of color I think to
find out because the media doesn't tell
you that and the right or the left
really has kind of reinforced reinforced
the the racial paradigms I think that
white equals rich in black equals four
and white equals stable and black equals
dysfunctional so a lot of times it was
more you know it's just I was very
welcomed in communities one particular
incident in your life that makes you
think that your experience was different
than your brothers or that you were a
survivor and it could could reach out I
think a lot of people these days are
talking about resilience and and what it
is that a lot of people want to study
people who are resilient and there were
survivors and the best response to that
I've heard because I had a little
problem with a lot of the emphasis on
resilience recently Geoffrey Canada
who's also a beacon press author was
being asked about this and I just loved
his response and his he grew up in the
South Bronx this African American grew
up poor in the South Bronx
it has a story not unlike mine and he
works with children to this day and he
was asked about about resilience and and
he said we need to really start to
question why why we want to focus on the
few that survive it's almost like we
throw a hundred kids into raging waters
and to make it out alive and we say okay
let's spend a lot of money and study
those two kids rather than just not
throwing kids into raging waters anymore
and I feel like that I feel like my
brothers were just as talented and
potentially resilient as as I was there
was uh I mean they were smart my brother
Kevin who was involved in the streets
from the age of 12 I would say was
probably the smartest in the family but
some there are some things that I
noticed in writing the book about my
place in the family being in the being
born in the aftermath of a baby that
died and also being a small child that
was able to witness my mother in in in
mourning a lot of that stuff probably
helped to create my perceptions of the
world and and and probably promoted
survival in a lot of ways and also as a
teenager my ability to step outside of
any craziness in my in my life and my
family in my community and to step
outside of it and to be say I'm that's
not gonna determine me and and to be
proud to be different that's I think an
important part of resilience it is
important to look at that in people's
lives but at the same time I think we're
only focusing on those kids rather than
I mean just getting rid of these
conditions that that destroy young
people's lives and these days we're
talking about we this beyond places like
Roxbury or Southie and we need to look
at it in places like Littleton Colorado
now we've been saying for a long time
activists in this field that that you
know this stuff is gonna spread and it's
happening thank you
[Applause]
grab the chairs inside I'll be big help
please come on up and say hello